the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
all right my friends i am back with
another episode from my very own version
of game of thrones season 9.
i still don't know how many episodes i
will make but i do know my story is
nearing its end
as all of the remaining characters make
their way back down to king's landing
for one final major showdown
i would like to get started right away
so let's go ahead and jump right into
this next episode
shall we begin like i said this is my
version of game of thrones season 9
episode 7 which i have named a dragon
reborn
in the very first scene of this episode
we will go down south on the sacred isle
of faces
there is a full moon in the night sky
sitting directly above the massive
werewood at the center of the god's eye
its reflection can be seen on the lake
giving us just enough light to see
what's standing on the shore
no different than any other night the
green men are standing their silent
watch over the ancient werewoods
while they stand their silent watch over
the sacred island
the black green and red dragonglass in
their spears is glowing under the
moonlit sky
everything and everyone on the island is
silent
except for the thousands of red leaves
dancing in the wind
the faces on the werewoods are as
frightening as ever
their blood-filled eyes are staring back
at us as a red-like substance drips down
from them
onto the ground we then begin to make
our way into the middle of the god's eye
all of the white walkers who were once
here riding on the backs of their giant
elks are now gone
there is still a very large fire burning
at the center of the island
where westeros's largest werewolf sits
surrounded by
seven more werewoods that are all facing
inward at the orange and red flames
the face on this massive werewood looks
horrific
its mouth is so large a grown man could
easily walk right through it without
ducking
as we stare into its blood-red eyes that
are full of secrets and ancient wisdom
hundreds of ravens suddenly explode from
the weirwood's gaping mouth
their black wings fill the sky and their
loud shrieking brings an end to this
silent night
this is when the children of the forest
begin to emerge from the woods
their great big golden cat's eyes are
now glowing in the shadows
the sound of branches breaking in leaves
crunching can be heard as they make
their way to the center of the aisle
there are seven of them each holding
dragonglass weapons of their own
one by one they begin jumping into the
mouth of the massive werewood sitting in
the middle of the grove
as we follow them inside we immediately
notice the werewolf's mouth is filled
with hundreds of skulls of those who
were once sacrificed to the old gods
over the centuries
the inside of this giant werewood drops
down into a cave system
like the one we have seen out beyond the
wall only this one has more light
allowing us to see much further into the
dark abyss
the seven children of the forest begin
ascending down deep into the earth
the scene ends as we watch them vanish
into the unknown
only they know what lies ahead but you
will find out soon enough
in the following scene we are back in
the capital of westeros
the sun is slowly starting to rise over
king's landing as the city begins to
wake up
there are men and women opening up their
small shops and markets for business
there are wagons full of new arrivals
entering the city every day
they're small children running through
the streets as some older kids are
chasing behind them
once again the scent of raw sewage and
freshly baked bread hangs heavy in the
morning air
there's about a dozen black ravens
circling in the sky above the red keep
as samwell and davos emerge from within
the castle
they begin walking over to the main gate
where there are some men of the city
watch standing guard
davos begins saying something to sam but
he doesn't hear what he says because
he's busy looking over at the ground
where he remembers seeing sir brawn's
lifeless body
the dried blood that was once on the
stone street has been washed away
but sam will never forget what he saw
that day he suddenly stops walking
then looks over at the city watch to
make sure they are out of earshot before
he interrupts davos
by asking him have he heard any new
developments regarding what happened to
sir brawn
has anyone found out what actually
happened i wish i could give you that
information
says sir davos but i'm afraid i do not
know i was about to ask you the same
thing
what about lorterion says samwell have
you spoke to him about it
wood that i could says sir davos but i
haven't spoke to him about it either
as a matter of fact i haven't seen lord
tyrion since the day we discovered brawn
had fallen from your grace's balcony
sam nervously looks into davos's eyes
then whispers
i'm not so sure he fell sir brawn would
have no reason to be in king branch
chambers
or on his balcony unless he was sent for
davos slowly looks up at the red key
as he thinks about what sam just said
you're right
davos says reluctantly the balcony has a
railing that stops anyone from falling
over so easily
he fell because someone shoved him sam
says dreadfully
they are suddenly interrupted by the
sound of riders arriving at the main
gate
as sam begins walking over he shouts
open the gates
these men are with me when the three
riders dismount from their horses
the guards from the city watch open the
gates allowing them inside
one of these riders removes a letter
from inside his sleeve before handing it
over to sam
without saying a word sam smiles and
nods his head at the men
who immediately begin mounting their
horses again
davos looks confused by this brief
interaction
sam starts walking away as he breaks the
wax seal on the letter
wondering what just happened davos stops
him demanding to know who those men were
and why they hand delivered him this
letter sam grabs him by the arm
then walks him away from the main gate
where the men of the city watch are
still standing guard
sam looks around making sure no one else
can hear them
in a low voice he says it's from the
citadel
davos is visibly unsatisfied with that
answer
so he says well what's it about what's
with all of this secrecy
sam takes a moment before he says when i
left the citadel
let's just say i borrowed some of their
books what do you mean borrowed
davos says doubtfully fine says sam i
stole some books from the citadel but i
had every intention of giving them back
once i was done with them
however something happened to one of the
books before i could do that
one of them was about the legends of the
long night i noticed something very
interesting on the front of that book
so i brought it to king bran hoping he
could help me figure out what it meant
but for some reason he threw the book
into the fire this is when i first
started thinking something might be
wrong with bran
so i wrote a letter to the citadel
asking them if they could give me any
more information on the subject
the only thing is i never heard back
from them that's when i started thinking
bran might be intercepting all of the
ravens coming in and out of king's
landing
since the ravens were compromised i sent
riders of my own
they hand delivered my messages then
brought me back the archmaester's
findings
i don't know why but i believe bran
doesn't want me to know the answers i am
looking for
well i may finally hold them in my hand
davos is taken aback by all of this
he shakes his head in disbelief before
wiping the sweat from his forehead
after a long deep breath davos says what
does the letter say
sam stands beside him then holds it up
for both of them to read
we're not able to make out everything
the letter says but we do see a few
lines that are written down
we can see it says in regards to the
book about the legends of the long night
then further down the letter we're also
able to see it says
the green men on the isle of faces now
we focus on davos sam sam's face as they
finish reading the letter
sam's eyes widen and his mouth hangs
open as he sucks in a deep breath
we follow his eyes as they leave the
letter they
slowly look up at the red keep above
them this scene ends when sam notices
bran is now sitting out on his balcony
staring down at them in the following
scene we are back in winterfell
we are following helen reed as he makes
his way across the courtyard
the grounds are now flooded with house
stark soldiers and bannermen of the
north
it looks as if they're getting ready for
war dozens of men
are getting fitted for armor dozens of
other men
are handing out dragonglass weapons that
were left over from the long night
battle
while others are mounting their horses
helen raid heads for the godswood
where jon and sansa are standing before
the werewood
when he notices they are still in
conversation he stops for a moment so
they can finish
he grabs the large item from his back
before dropping it down onto the ground
he checks to make sure it's still fully
wrapped up in the fur
after securing it again he slings it
back over his shoulder
another minute goes by then helen reed
finally says
i'm sorry to disturb you your grace but
the men are just about saddled
and ready we must leave soon john looks
at sanzo with a bit of sadness in his
eyes
before opening up his arms and giving
her a big hug
the air is thick with us all in silence
lord halen reed watches as john whispers
something in her ear
when they let go of each other john
looks at helen reed and says
i'm ready john and sansa begin walking
over to where lord helen reed is
standing on the other side of the
godswood
the leaves and snow crunches underneath
their feet with each and every step
jon suddenly stops when he feels
something hard under his foot
he lifts his boot then reaches down and
grabs something that was half buried in
the ground
as he begins to brush away the snow he
immediately recognizes what it is
sansa says you're not the first one to
step on that i also found it before
but i wasn't sure what it was from jon
looks over at howland reed
who is looking at the object in his
hands jon says
this was the night kings i saw him
wearing this beyond the wall
and then again here in winterfell it
must have fallen from his uniform
after he was stabbed by arya this
reminds jon of what else he found not
long ago
he grabs something he has had stashed
inside of his fur overcoat
slanza can't believe what jon is holding
in his hands she says
is that bran's where did you find that
it was inside a cave out beyond the wall
it was where bran met the three-eyed
raven the same cave where i met the
children of the forest
and lord howland reed in one hand john
is holding the night king's metallic
symbol that he wore
around his neck in the other hand he is
holding bran's metallic stark choker
that he wore
on his neck he studies both of them for
a few moments
before sanzo finally grabs his arm and
says
john i sent ravens down to king's
landing hoping i could speak with bran
when they were left unanswered i sent
men down there as well
they still aren't back from the capitol
they won't be coming back
helen reed says ominously sansa's eyes
fill with anger as she says what
how do you know that i'm sorry your
grace but i did say your brother bran is
in grave danger if your men aren't back
yet
then they're dead already lord howland
then looks back in john's eyes and says
we must leave now the three of them
silently exit the godswood
john and halen's horses are already
waiting for them in the courtyard
as well as all the men who are now
leaving with them right before they
mount their horses
sansa stops helen reed she says do you
think this will be enough men
i've sent out more ravens but i'm not
sure if they will make it to their
destinations
lord howland looks around at all of the
men gathered inside the courtyard
and the men who are mounted just outside
of the gate there's maybe 700 soldiers
or fewer
i won't lie to you you grace i honestly
don't know if this will be enough
but it's certainly better than what we
had before we stopped here
this amount of men does help but it will
also slow us down
the underground system isn't big enough
for this many men we will have to find a
way to make do what the circumstances we
are in
your grace thank you says sansa lord
hallon bows his head
before knocking his heels against his
horse as jon and sansa watch the men
begin to leave the courtyard
she says one last thing to jon before he
goes south
this scene ends right after sansa says
john
i want you to get our brother out of
king's landing bring him home
as john and his horse are leaving
through winterfell's main gate
he looks back over his shoulder then
says i will
in the next scene we go back out at sea
where there are roughly 100
ships sailing under the bright sunlight
the sun's reflection is bouncing off the
deep blue sea
but it's suddenly swallowed up by a
massive shadow flying above
drogon soars across the sky as he
overlooks all of the ships down below
he's drinking up the morning sun as he
stretches his wings and glides through
the hazy air
the sails of the fiery heart and the
three-headed dragon are flapping hard in
the wind
the scene begins as we see kinvara
standing on the deck of the ship
and our long scarlet silk robe we can
see the sun in her eyes as she glares
into the sky at drogon
she stares at the dragon for several
moments but she finally looks away when
she hears daenerys walking her way
kinvara notices dany has a look of
discomfort written all over her face
as she approaches her kinvara says is
everything all right your grace
no says daenerys i am still worried
about grey worm
i haven't seen him since last night he
is still locked inside one of the cabins
with the man you brought with us
mokaro kenvara smiles then reaches out
and grabs daenerys by her hand
you will see him soon enough your grace
says kinvara
greyworm's flesh was kissed by fire he
is not as resistant to the flames like
you have been before
he let his emotions get the best of him
he was foolish for grabbing the burning
brazier
before slamming it down onto the deck of
the ship there are no maesters on board
with us
but lucky for him we have macaro if
anyone here will be able to fix grey
worm
it will be him as she lets go of her
hand daenerys says
some of your soldiers said they heard
wild laughter coming from inside
makaro's cabin
laughter that was deep and dark and mad
later
they said they heard him singing some
song in high valyrian
kinvara smiles again she says see for
yourself
daenerys stormborn here they come now
when daenerys looks over her shoulder
she can see greyworm and mccarro are
walking their way
danny notices greyworm is naked from the
waist up
his right hand is wrapped in bandages
but his left hand looks very disturbing
the other men standing around the ship
begin whispering and trading glances
as they get a look at grey worm's arm is
everything okay says daenerys
after grey worm and macaro stop in front
of her let me have a look at your hand
says kinvara
greyworm raised a charred and blackened
hand
it was bloody all the way up to his
elbow even black smoke rose from his
fingers
a horrified daenerys says i will find
you a maester as soon as we reach
westeros
that is not necessary says mccarro i
have fixed his hand your grace
danny then looks back at grey worm
waiting for him to say something
i am fine your grace says grey worm my
hand feels even stronger than it did
before
it feels like there is a fire running
through the veins in my hand
makaro smiles then walks away back below
the deck
grey worm then looks at kinvara and says
may i speak with your grace alone
of course says kinvara who smiles bowser
head
then leaves as well when they're finally
alone daenerys asks him again
are you sure everything is okay yes your
grace i swear my hand feels fine
but there is something else i think we
should discuss okay
says daenerys with a bit of hesitation
in her voice what would you like to
discuss
it's jon snow says grey worm i am
worried about what might happen
once we land in westeros again this
kinvara says we will need him
but i don't know how much i believe her
he has already shown us that he cannot
be trusted your grace
you have said that we need to stop
brandon stark but that's jon snow's
brother
what happens if jon has to choose
between saving you
or saving his own brother what happens
if brain attempts to harm you
would jon kill his own brother to save
you because i don't think he will
i think the opposite is more likely to
happen your grace
danny looks out at the deep blue sea
that surrounds them
she watches as drogon flies down low
before he skims right above the water
after another moment of silence daenerys
finally says
i do understand your concerns i have
some of my own
some days i walk out onto this deck look
out at the sea
and wonder if i should go back to
westeros at all
sometimes i wonder if i should risk my
own life to save those who may never
love me
on other days i walk out onto this deck
look out at the sea
and think about killing jon snow as soon
as we land in westeros
those dark thoughts eventually fade away
when i remember
why i wanted to take back the iron
throne that i thought was rightfully
mine
i don't want to be remembered the same
way as everyone remembers my father
some of the anchor starts to leave
greyworm's eyes i want to save those who
can't save themselves
says daenerys that's one of the reasons
why so many were willing to follow me
if i can't fight for that then it was
all for nothing
westeros and even the entire realm is
right back where we started
i have decided that if i am going to
live i can't live with that
daenerys begins slowly walking away but
then she stops and looks back at grey
worm
she says but then again words are just
when
if i am being honest i don't know how i
will react when i see jon snow again
grey worm lifts his head back up he
looks over at danny
and there is a fire in his eyes again as
daenerys goes to walk away
greyworm stops her he says your grace i
saw jon snow on the back of drogon when
can vara had me look in her flames
if jon rides drogon what does that mean
happen to you
there is a bit of sadness in dany's eyes
when she softly says
i don't know the scene ends right after
grey worm says
i won't let you out of my sight again
your grace when we arrive in westeros
i will kill jon snow myself in the next
scene we are back in king's landing
we follow samwell and sir davos as they
are walking inside of the red key
the sound of their footsteps scare off
some of the ravens that are in the great
hall
where the iron throne once set as they
are making their way across the throne
room
davos and sam hold their hands over
their nose when they start smelling a
horrible stench
the ravens have nearly finished eating
the unknown dead man who has been laying
in the great hall
all week when sam and davos look over at
what's left of him
all we see is basically a skeleton
dressed in bloody rags
there is a raven standing on the rotting
man's skull watching davos and sam with
hatred in its black eyes
the raven watches them until they're out
of sight when sam and davos finally
arrive in the small council's chambers
they sit in their seats and wait there
is an ominous silence in the small
council room
davos looks around at all of the empty
seats beside them
we watch them sit here in silence for
what feels like several minutes
at last davos throws a glance sam's way
and says how early are we they should be
here already says sam
we have our meetings at this hour every
week maybe lortyrian is running late
says sir davos
it certainly wouldn't be the first time
sam smiles nervously
before he says no it would not but that
doesn't answer for sir podrick and
brienne
does brienne strike you as someone who
runs late
no she doesn't says sir davos now sam
begins looking around the room at all of
the empty seats
braun is dead but lord tyrion sir
podrick and berean
and even king bran are not at their
scheduled meeting
that's when they begin hearing the sound
of boots walking their way
they eagerly stand up hoping to see
their other advisors walk in and join
them
instead a man dressed in the golden
kingsguard armor stands before them
hello says sam as he smiles the
kingsguard man doesn't smile
nor does he greet sam back this is one
of the same men who arrested lord tyrion
as well as brienne and sarpadric follow
me
says the member of the kingsguard but we
have a meeting says sam
we are waiting for the others there will
be no meeting today
says the king's guardman i'm only here
because your grace said i would find
both of you here he gave me orders to
locate both of you
then bring you with me to join him
follow me he's right this way
as the member of the kingsguard begins
walking away sam and davos look at each
other with confusion
they don't fully understand what's
happening wait a minute says davos
you will have to forgive me sir but we
have never seen you before
who are you and where did you get that
armor the king's guardman smiles
as he slowly starts walking davos's way
until he's standing right in front of
him
he stares long and hard into his eyes
but then he abruptly jams the handle of
his sword
into davos's stomach forcing him to fall
down to one knee
as davos tries finding his breath the
king's guard member says
your grace is the only man i answer to
now
as i said before follow me your king
commands it
sam rushes over helping davos get back
on his feet
after he finally catches his breath
davos and sam reluctantly follow the
kingsguard man out of the room
then down the stairs they both feel an
overwhelming sense of dread
sam's feet feel heavier after each and
every step
as they make their ascension down the
stairs they begin hearing
what sounds like a large crowd gathered
outside it grows louder and louder as
they get closer to the doors
sam and davos look at each other with
uncertainty when they reach the main
entrance of the red keep
the king's guardman swings open the
doors they are momentarily blinded by
the sunlight
and the sound of a thousand voices
shouting makes them feel a little
disoriented
sam rubs his eyes as he looks around at
the crowd gathering outside
davos holds his stomach as he follows
them around the side of the red key
samwell and sir davos are shocked by
what they see up ahead
they see bran sitting on a very large
platform about a hundred feet away
a few men are seen behind him setting up
the gallows for an execution
right in front of bran is lortyrian
brienne and podrick
all of them are down on their knees with
their hands behind their backs
each of them have a gag in their mouth
as well standing right next to bran are
the other new members of the kingsguard
sam and davos rush through the crowd as
they make their way up to the stage
davos yells out your grace what is the
meaning of this
why are they bound and gagged however
bran doesn't answer him
instead sam and davis are immediately
arrested by the new sworn brothers of
the kingsguard
one of bran's guards leans in close to
davos and sam
he says don't say another word let this
serve as a lesson
now enjoy the show sam and davis are
stunned by this shocking turn of events
suddenly bran lifts his arms in the air
silencing the large crowd gathered in
front of them
when the screaming and shouting begins
to soften brain says
it's very unfortunate that we have to
meet under these circumstances but it
seems there are some rebels among us
lord tyrion lannister your very own hand
of the king
is guilty of murdering his friend our
master of coin
sir bronify garden lady berean and sir
podrick have always been on the side of
the lannisters
this is when one of brandt's king's
guard shouts lady buran even laid with a
lannister
she slept with sir jamie lannister the
kingslayer she has also written lies
about him in our white book
making him out to be some sort of hero
the crowd erupts when they hear this
we hear some of them shouting the
lannisters have always been murderers
kill them all some of them begin
spitting at berean
while others are throwing rocks at lord
tyrion after a few moments of this
bran lefts his arms again silencing
everyone there
he says i gave brienne a chance to show
her loyalty
all she had to do was kill lord tyrion
show
us that once and for all you no longer
favor the lannisters
but she would not do this it seems that
lady berean would rather die
than to honor her king well lady brienne
i will give you one more chance
bran gives a signal to one of the
kingsguard who then walks over and
removes
the gag from brienne's mouth i will ask
you again
in front of everyone says bran who do
you fight for lady brienne
will you defend your king by slaying
this murderous lion of lannister
or will you die beside him you must
decide
here and now the sword or the noose
as the tears are falling from brian's
face she helplessly looks over at sir
podrick
who has sadness in his eyes as well he
shakes his head no he doesn't want
brienne to break her on her
by giving him what he wants she now
looks over at lord tyrion
who is covered in his own sweat in urine
brienne looks into bran's eyes
it seems like all of his life has left
them as he stares back at her
emotionless
finally she says i will not make that
choice
the crowd explodes into shouting again
then
so be it says brynn your fate has been
sealed
he looks at his new sworn brothers of
the kingsguard then says
hang them first brienne and sir podrick
are yanked up onto their feet
sam and davis are even more horrified
than before
they know there is nothing they can do
to stop this the nooses were slipped
around their necks then jerked tight
one of the brothers of the kingsguard
looks at brienne then says
if you have any other crimes you want to
confess to your gods
now would be the time to say them when
she doesn't answer him
he smiles then says you're the strong
silent type i see
have it your way lady brienne now let's
see if you can dance
he yanked on a rope hard before the
floor fell out from under brienne and
sir podrick's feet
brienne immediately felt the hemp
constricting around her neck
digging into her skin forcing her chin
upward
it sounds like lorterion is cursing at
them through his gag
but not the boy sir podrick never lifted
his eyes
not even when his feet jerked up off the
ground brienne thought
if this is some bad dream it is time for
me to awaken
if this is real it is time for me to die
all she could see was sir podrick
the noose around his thin neck and his
legs as they started to spasm
he was kicking choking and dying
her mouth opened she sucked the air in
desperately
even as the rope was strangling her
nothing had ever hurt so much
this scene ends right after brienne
screams a word in the final scene of
this episode
we go back below the ground somewhere
under westeros
we are following seven small shadows as
they move through the darkness that lies
ahead
one of them is holding a light but we're
still not able to see enough to make out
who they are
we keep following the seven shadows as
they move further and further into the
black abyss
it's not long before they spill out into
a large open cave
when this happens their light reflects
off the cave walls
revealing who they are it's the seven
children of the forest who jumped into
the mouth of the massive werewolf
on the isle of faces there is now
standing inside of a cave that has
familiar drawings all over its walls
as we see more and more drawings on the
walls we realize it's the same cave john
and daenerys were in on dragonstone
these seven small creatures walk through
the cave until they emerge out onto the
beach
there is a full blood moon in the sky
the empty large castle looms over them
as they form a circle near the edge of
the water
all seven of them are now facing inward
at each other
that's when each of them simultaneously
grab their dragonglass daggers
before they make a small incision on
their hand
as the blood drips down from their hands
it falls onto the sand
and a small wave of water comes up to
their feet the salt water washes away
their blood
before sucking it back out to the sea
now they shut their eyes
as they start saying something in a
language unknown by man it sounds more
like they're singing a song
a song of the earth this is when
something very strange starts to happen
dark clouds begin forming right above
them lightning starts to strike
thunder begins to crack the sound of the
wind gets very loud
as it throws sand all over the beach
suddenly
a lightning bolt strikes down onto
dragonstone leaving a very large
crack across the face of the stone
castle the seven children of the forest
begin
chanting louder and louder as the dark
clouds above them get even more violent
the waves in the sea are getting larger
but they're not smashing into the shore
it's almost as if the ocean water is
lifting directly up into the sky
the children finally opened their eyes
all we see is white
again their chanting grows even louder
as the thunder snaps and
cracks like a whip as the sea water
begins moving faster
in a circular direction another bolt of
lightning
strikes down right into the center of
the swirling water
as soon as the dark clouds begin to open
up the children's chanting stops
but in that exact moment it looks as if
an explosion goes off in the water
millions of gallons of sea water flies
up into the sky
as a black shadow emerges above we
suddenly hear the ear splitting scream
of a dragon
with their dark magic the children have
summoned rhaegal from below the sea
it's the most frightening thing we have
ever seen the dragon's eyes are now
red because it was decomposing in the
salt water for so long
some of its scales are slipping right
off of its bones
the large holes in his neck and chest
allow us to see its fire burning inside
of him at all times
the episode ends as the dragon
disappears
into the night sky
[Music]
so
you